I tend to think that's it you know that
that is the message that the message is
that the mind is poised on on a
precipice of incomprehension and that
there are you know as Shakespeare said
more things in heaven and earth than are
dreamt of in your philosophy
Horacio that the enterprise of
understanding is dizzying I mean it's an
ecstasy in itself that's why to me what
the essence of being psychedelic is is
the flirtation with detail and
multiplicity I mean that's why I'm so
fascinated by history because it's such
a complex object
I like complex stuff history art history
philosophy languages magic all of these
things I like the well wrought and
complex the pattern turned in upon
itself the place where mind has moved
across the sand and left the tracing and
in all of that then there is some kind
of satisfaction you know in ruins in
books in forgotten places in the places
where people haven't been poking around
so long I mean the river of cognition is
broad and deep and many people are you
know worrying about - I don't know the
Simpsons or something like that but over
at the fractal edges of the great river
the peculiar and the bizarre the little
dealt with is flourishing
you